>>Daniel: I've always had this kind
of secret talk radio host fantasy,
so I'm gonna play that
out this afternoon,
and we have a great lineup here
on Castle Radio this afternoon,
really outstanding guests.
To my left, immediate
left, is Mark Greenberg.
Mark is Edna Bennett chair of
prevention at Penn State University.
He directs Penn State's
Prevention Research Center
for the promotion of
human development.
Maurice Elias is a professor of
psychology at Rutger's University,
the president elect of the Society
for Community Research and Action.
He's also the senior
author promoting social
and emotional learning
guidelines for educators.
Larry Abner, Larry's
professor of applied psychology
and public policy at
New York University.
There he serves as board
chair of the new Institute
for Human Development
and Social Change.
And finally, we have George
Lucas who needs no introduction,
because he founded GLEF,
which we all worship.
>>That's your claim to fame.
>>Daniel: Because it's so effective
in getting the message out,
so let me take people one by one.
And first in the guest
chair is Mark Greenberg.
So let's just start by
seeing where are we starting?
What do you think the most
important scientific developments
in SEL are so far?
>>Mark: The message this
morning is critically important,
and that is that social and
emotional learning programs
in carefully done randomized trials
not only affect children's social
development and their
emotional processing,
but they dramatically affect
the academic achievement.
This effect size of point
two eight is as large
as almost any effect size.
Even reading achievement
interventions don't change reading
achievement in most cases more than
social emotional learning does.
And that's because, as Dan said
many years ago, it's a master skill.
It's a skill that underlies all
kinds of achievements in learning.
You know that in the nineteen
eighties, an experiment was stopped
because we found that aspirin,
by taking aspirin each day,
we reduced our rate of heart disease.
The effect size for that is
less than point one oh, okay?
The effect size of the social
emotional learning programs
on academic achievement
is point two eight.
It's almost three times
that effect size.
So we need to use language, I agree
with, language is very important,
that we can get a sense of
the proportion of this effect.
That's an effect that
literally can change the lives
of millions of American children.
>>Daniel: When you go to a school
and you say, "We've got this program.
We want you to start doing it,"
and teachers are so hard pressed,
don't you get a lot of pushback?
"We don't have time for this."
What's your response to that?
>>Maurice: I frankly find that
this message was not something
that people wanted to hear ten years
ago, but I think they're ready.
I think they're ready, and
in New Jersey, of course,
we have a way of making
sure they're ready.
But in New Jersey,
the State Department
of Education is actually funding an
effort that's now in its third year,
developing safe and civil
schools, which has as its mission
to bring social and emotional
and character development
to all twenty-four
hundred New Jersey schools.
So the aspiration is there, the
support is there, it's possible.
>>Daniel: Let me ask you this, we've
been hearing that it's important
to get to schools of education.
At the same time, Roger's showing
that teachers can do this very well.
Do you think that teachers need some
extra training before they become
teachers, and how seamless is
it really, getting a teacher
up to speed to teach SEL?
>>Maurice: There's nothing
pedagogically challenging about most
of what we ask teachers to do in
various SEL curricular programs,
nothing beyond what they have to
do in most of their other pedagogy.
Teachers are not used to
their language of emotions,
and I think that's the
single biggest issues
that we have to help them with.
They don't know how to talk
to children about emotions
and they're afraid how to respond
when children mention
difficult emotions.
And I think that's something that
should be part of teachers' training,
because it's going to be what
they're faced with in the classroom.
>>Daniel: Larry, you're really
an expert on education policy
and it looks to me like
we've got a really good case
from a scientific point of view
and a practice point of view,
of bringing SEL into schools,
but it's not that easy, isn't it?
There's a little thing called policy,
and what do you think it would take
to convince key policy
decision makers to go for this?
>>Larry: Well, the first thing I
wanna say is, I'm grateful for my--
my brother from New
Jersey's comments,
and I'd like to see the
whole family working.
On a much more serious note,
policy is a gigantic task.
I have the opportunity to talk about
policy in front of George Miller
and Ed Ziegler and then
allude to one or two issues
about communications
right before George Lucas,
so take my comments in their context.
One of the things that I think we've
heard already from the meeting today,
and from Castle's work, is that
policy exists at multiple levels.
It exists from the building level and
community level, through the district
and municipality level, to the
state level, to the national level
and indeed to the international
level.
So I think explicit policy strategies
that recognize all of those levels,
trying to create an echo
chamber, trying to create things
that reinforce instead of
detract from each other
at these multiple levels is one part.
We need top down, bottom up
and middle out strategies.
And policy equals politics, so Janice
Jackson said the big R word hasn't
been described and used
much in this meeting.
The other word is culture wars.
We use the umbrella term,
social emotional learning.
Red America uses the term social and
character development, and somehow,
solving some of the political
issues related to, is this social
and character development, and is it
religion and morals and values based,
or is it social emotional learning,
and is it science and
rationale based?
That has to be solved.
George Miller has scars all
over his body associated
with the challenge of, do you do this
as evidence based or as values based?
>>Daniel: What's your
answer, what's the most-- ?
>>Larry: Yes, it has to be both.
We have to align both, and we've
talked a lot about communications.
We're going to talk about
communications more.
Anybody in this room
who hasn't looked
at the Frameworks Institute's
website, www.frameworksinstitute.org,
it is about evidence based
communications strategies.
The words we use, how they call
up, in Pedro Noguera's terms,
our assumptions about what
the causes of the problem are,
and how they dispose toward
preferred policy solutions.
So we have to apply the same
rigor to policy development
and to message development
associated with policies
as we apply to our science.
>>Daniel: You have gotten to
actually stake your ground
in the education world as a
communicator, as finding the way
to message the meat, so to speak, you
know, what works, what's promising,
what's a beautiful vision, and
taking it to a public in a way
that people resonate with.
>>George: Our mission really is to
help facilitated high technology
in the schools, and what that did
was take us to a place where, okay,
you've got your computers
in your schools,
now what do you do with them?
But that took us into what we
call project based learning
and collaborative learning,
which is basically what this is,
and interdisciplinary
studies, and a lot of things
that don't have anything
to do with technology,
but the technology allows this to
happen, and they're all connected.
So we sorta look at a bigger picture
in which emotional
intelligence is one part of it.
But when you start to
pull everything all apart,
you realize that everything depends
on everything else in order to work.
A computer allows you
to do a project.
A project allows you to do it with
two or three people at a time.
That basically demands
emotional intelligence.
It's not just for the recess, you
know, where you learn who gets
to go on the jungle gym first.
It's actually, you know, and I
hear it from my own kids, you know,
they say, "Well, I gotta do
this project with so and so.
I hate him."
And I say, "Well, you know,
that's the way the world is.
You're gonna have to learn
to work with people you hate.
That's just the way it works,
and it's not gonna go away
and you're gonna have
to learn how to do it."
And to have the teachers
as facilitators explain it
to the students ahead of time,
"This is how you make this work,"
then their projects not only become
the academic project, but it becomes
and emotional challenge
of, "How do I work
with somebody and make this happen?"
I like to say, you know, unless
you're a college professor
or a scientist, you're never
gonna get fired for being stupid.
You're only gonna get fired for
not being able to work with people,
and that's usually the way
it works in the real world.
>>Daniel: Actually, I saw a study of
CEOs which showed that they got hired
for their business expertise
and their intelligence,
but they got fired for lapses in
social and emotional learning.
>>George: Yeah.
>>Daniel: Which brings up the
question of, if you were going to try
to sell this, to get this
message to the business community,
what would you emphasize?
>>George: Well, again, it's the
ability to work with other people.
Any business, they know this.
All businesses know this.
They all know that what they want
is people who are team builders,
who are able to work
with other people,
who are able to inspire other people,
who are able to, without conflict,
get other people to do things
or change their ways
or this sort of thing.
And if you can say, "This is
going to make that happen"
to the business community, I'm
sure they would embrace it,
because that's their biggest problem.
>>Daniel: But what would
your message to parents be?
I mean, don't parents really
care if their children are happy
and doing well in school?
I mean, don't you need
to change language-- ?
>>George: But that's where some
of these statistics, you know,
the fact that they
do better on tests.
I mean, to me, that's the biggest
sales point here, is to say,
"They will do better
on their test scores
if they understand
emotional intelligence."
That would get a parent behind it.
If we can bring down the incidence of
violence in our school by doing this,
and we can save some money by having
less police officers on the campus,
well, that's a good argument.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org